a woman's account of her childhood
experience off-the-grid inspired a
critically acclaimed memoir airwest
overs book educated chronicles her
account of growing up isolated with her
family in the Idaho mountains her father
was a survivalist who distrusted all
forms of government Tara Westover writes
that as a child quote we had no medical
records because we were born at home we
have no school records because we never
set foot in a classroom at this moment
according to the state of Idaho and the
federal government I do not exist
Westover charted her own path attending
college at seventeen earning a PhD from
Cambridge University how did she do that
Tara's book is already on Amazon's
bestseller list and she joins us at the
table to discuss Tara first
congratulations and Bravo I've never
read a story like this and I look at you
I was curious to see what is she gonna
look like and you walked in here looking
so normal I was relieved too but let us
give us a sense of your childhood you're
the youngest of seven kids you don't
even know what your exact birthdate is I
don't I've narrowed it down to a couple
of days so I was raised on this
beautiful mountain in Idaho and it
really was a beautiful place but my
father had these radical beliefs and
because of those beliefs we were a bit
isolated so like you said there was no
school we never went to the doctor not
even when we were injured and my father
had a junkyard so we got injured a lot
quite amazing yeah and you had head for
the hills bags yeah guys had to be
packed ready to go at all times yeah
there was a lot of skepticism and fear
of the federal government and that
possibly because of the way we were
living but they might kind of come maybe
try to force us go to go to school that
kind of thing your father believed that
all these forms of government were
agents of the Illuminati right yeah he
had this idea that something had
infiltrated all of these institutions
whether it was doctors and hospitals or
public education yeah he was very
concerned about them described for
people working in the junk yard was like
you were just sorting seatbelts no I
mean it was it was quite dangerous and I
don't think it's that my dad didn't
value our safety he just didn't have
that bone in his head that said this is
dangerous don't do it like this and so
we would get injured a lot and then
because he had these beliefs about
doctors and hospitals then we would
treat those injuries at home
you were impaled your brother's leg
caught on fire your father was severely
injured by an explosion and those were
all treated at home by your mother who
was making tinctures and essential oils
in the kitchen yeah and my father's
injury was the worst of all of them I
mean he was standing next to a car when
it exploded and he was really badly
burned so I think it proves it wasn't
that he didn't care about us it's just
the way that his mind worked or the
beliefs that he had it just wasn't
yeah just he was going to live that way
a big part of the book is the
relationship that you have with your one
of your older brothers you know you give
him a pseudonym in the book you give him
the name Sean you name your other
brothers but sean is a pseudonym and he
was extremely emotionally and physically
abusive with you yes he was and when I
confronted my parents about with that
information they decided to try to
convince me that I was insane and I
couldn't trust my own memories and old
to me that ultimately that would lead to
an estrangement from my family at first
that was their choice they ostracized me
for speaking up about my brother and
then eventually it took me a lot of
years but then that was all so much and
it's important to say that you have four
brothers Tony Tyler Richard and Luke you
are not talking about any of those
you're talking about Sean and you've
given him a fake name exactly we should
note that your parents have their lawyer
anyway has issued a statement about the
memoir and it says Terra was a love
daughter who was educated by her parents
such that at age 16 she received a
scholarship from BYU as school that it
is not that is not easy to get into like
her two brothers that got PhDs
homeschooling was a sufficient
sufficient foundation for their
education how do you react to that well
one of the reasons I wrote the book is
because of the gaslighting I experienced
for my parents their continual denial of
things that were happening like with my
brother and so I guess for me I would
say I love my parents I believe they're
good people but I think but I think the
tragedy here isn't that bad people do
bad things
I think the tragedy is what good people
do to keep secrets we aren't able to go
get an education to go to Harvard to go
to Cambridge to go to BYU when you would
not really bend to a classroom well I
have another brother who had done
thing he'd educated himself he had
bought the books and he had just taught
it to himself and he told me that I
should I should try to go to college so
I bought an a CT study guide I tried to
teach myself enough math and grammar
you bought textbooks and I learned
enough to kind of scrape through the a
CT I mean that statement isn't
completely factual I didn't have a
scholarship I barely scraped in to be
what you but I did earn one eventually
through getting grades but it was it was
really difficult I mean I arrived I
didn't know what the Holocaust was I
once asked what it was until you told it
as well came across a word you had never
seen before
and you said I don't know this word and
everybody looked at you like were they
they thought I was denying it they
thought I was denying because what is
this I think they heard it that way but
I'm in it completely sincerely I didn't
know what it was did you have to write
this book a lot of it what it's about is
claiming your own story from other
people who are trying to tell you your
story did you have to in order to
complete that I felt like I needed to
come to terms with the decision I had
made to let go of my family and I think
when I was writing the book the big
questions to me were what does it mean
to belong to a family and what
obligations do we have to our family and
are there limits to those obligations
and what do you do when you want to be
loyal to your family but you feel that
loyalty to them is in conflict somehow
with loyalty to yourself you said it's
possible to love and hate at the same
time and you said in families like ours
no crime is worse than telling the truth
what's your relationship like with your
family today half my family I'm close
with and then half I'm estranged from
even the half I'm estranged from I love
them and I don't feel that angry towards
them cuz I think anger is a mechanism
that you need to get you out of
dangerous situations things that will
harm you but once you're out once you're
safe you don't even anymore you can live
a better life without it you talk to
your mom and dad I email with my mother
occasionally yeah a little bit but I try
to limit that because I did have a bit
of a mental breakdown trying to with my
parents they really succeeded in
convincing me that I was insane for a
while about my brother and I had a
complete mental breakdown and there's
only so much of that that I can have in
my life and kind of keep hold of my
grasp of sanity and reality and no
terror really Bravo you say mental
breakdowns never obvious to people that
are having them it's an amazing story
thank you so much for sharing it thank
you
with us today educated is on sale now
wherever you like to buy your books